okay let's see if i can win against what
he usually goes for some variation of
the slav
let's see which one he has in store
today
so we'll have the semi-slab let's go
bishop g5
see what he's got
ipd7
oh he goes for the for the cambridge
springs
it's not a bad opening but he has
suffered a bit in these lines
so which one do i want to go for
i'll go cd5
95 this is the old
main line and then rick c1 is the new
move
i think yeah so the point here is
usually white would go queen d2
but then the more modern move is just to
to to omit that to go a3 immediately
so b6 what's the point here for white
so queen d2 i think just transposes to
to normal lines no generally if you take
on a3
just white gets e4 and very good
compensation with the bishop pair
now i don't remember this
so we'll just play play normal
uh h6 is useful since the bishop is a
little bit worse on h4
since it has only one diagonal
rather than two to work on
i had this ending as black against gary
meyer once
um in the dresden olympiad in 2008.
i think i also had it against evan chuck
in in
in 2009 in leon rapid as white
both of those games were drawn um
but i was definitely worse against meyer
at some point
also there were some titanic battles
that cheer up had in this lioness black
i think both against kramnik
and oroni and he was defending these
positions
and um i feel like i've seen artemis
play them as well
generally white is a little bit better
but
black holes
i'm not sure
knight d6 i think i'll go bishop g3 and
then
um a4 maybe
let's just go a4
i'm probably going to get hanging pawns
here eventually in the
in the center on c4 and d4 after he's
taken and then
the a4 lever is important either forcing
him to take
so that the c pawn is passed or that i
can take on b6
and create a weak pawn on b6
okay so we just castles
interesting he wants a quick rook fd8
with with counterplay
so i feel like people
normally castle hair is white and not
kingy too
i don't really know why so i'm gonna go
kini too i feel like
i feel like yeah the
king there might be enough pieces here
in the center
that the king doesn't belong belong
there
um but i i could see things
opening up here in a way and
like like we we have in some previous
games since it's really becoming a theme
as well that i'm playing with the bishop
player
in almost every game somehow against his
knights
i mean he is very good at
handling the knights but i feel like my
bishops should
eventually prevail in a few of these
games
um
yeah let's go g4 maybe
anticipating knight d6
oh 97 it's a little bit surprising to me
now i can potentially go 94 at some
point
okay a5
i think if it takes it i got knight b3
and knight c5
question is whether i can hold on to
everything here in the center because
if i can hold on then i'm gonna be
much much better strategically
knight c6 knight 26 then i take take
rook b1
now g6 is a
surprising move
okay let's go i don't know if i should
go bishop e3 okay let's go bishop e3
it seems a bit a bit saner
clearly i have to speed up this is going
to be another
another potential time travel game
yeah rugby with two rupee one
he's got no he's got some annoying
tricks
knight g2 is good you could also take on
beef
and d4 their first yeah i lost
i lost control here
okay four now
i think you should have got knight h4 no
i think i'm doing great
e5 rook b6 rook d8 knight p3
it's got knight g2 though just
getting a bit out of hand
he gives up a piece but it doesn't have
enough compensation here
okay let's go back
try and consolidate
okay g2 okay g3
it's still not at all an easy conversion
even though i'm a piece up
can i go knight c5 probably not
okay we'll go i have to go here though
92
let's go trade
take it
oh 96 he has to
try and at least come keep some pieces
here but now i think
knight c4 i'm winning f6 bishop d5
otherwise i just take
yeah good uh
i think yeah he had a better position at
some point but
what can i say i
[Music]
got it eventually